llegó en avión recorrió las calles de
bagdad en una caravana con un fuerte
despliegue de seguridad luego entró al
palacio presidencial se reunió con
autoridades y dio un discurso que estuvo
a la altura de las circunstancias no más
violencia no más extremismo facciones
intolerancias hay que darle espacio a
todos los ciudadanos que quieren
construir juntos en este país el en el
diálogo que ninguna confrontación franca
sincera y constructiva así comenzó la
primera visita de un pontífice a irak
quien visitará a cuatro ciudades en tres
días utilizando avión helicóptero y
automóvil es su primer viaje en 16 meses
tras haber detenido sus compromisos por
la pandemia un contexto que pone de
manifiesto el compromiso del papá
francisco en su visita a un país de
mayoría musulmana chiíta ha habido en
los últimos años
problemas de terrorismo conflictos
sectarios basados en un fundamentalismo
que no puede aceptar la coexistencia
pacífica de diferentes grupos étnicos de
ideas su segunda parada fue en la
catedral sirio cristiana nuestra señora
de la salvación epicentro del mayor acto
terrorista contra los cristianos en 2010
que dejó al menos 50 muertos
irak fue invadida por eeuu en 2003
poniendo fin a tres décadas de la
dictadura de sadam husein pero iniciando
dos décadas de guerra que culminaron con
el terror de estado islámico que
controló parte del país hasta 2017 un
contexto que ha afectado directamente a
los cristianos puesto que se cree que un
millón de personas han tenido que huir
desde entonces actualmente quedan cerca
de medio millón en un país de 40
millones de habitantes